I'm Julie Allison and I'm here with
Chris Anderson the editor-in-chief of
Wired who is so graciously agreed to
submit to a conversation with me yeah
yeah how'd that happen
this is what I think got you wanted the
cover it was it was after after you were
you were radar named you the ten one of
the ten most hated people number three
number three and and and you had to you
had to write your acceptance speech and
that you started of course as you know
the right way that while you hate me you
really would hate me so they you get you
get point points for comedy but that's
not enough thanks you know the question
is can you can you you know are you
gonna get defensive are you gonna you
know get weepy are you going to you know
you know get are you gonna get bite back
or something like that but no you you
you didn't you actually got serious this
is I think the sentence um I couldn't
done it without you she says to start be
curious the imaginary um I want to thank
my agent who has been with me since I
was just mildly annoying when people
criticize me i I always felt I never
felt that um all attention is good
attention yeah but I did feel like
people were laughing with me probably
more than they actually work my mother
after reading some of the online
comments stop speaking we stopped
speaking for a while and until she felt
like I was on the right track actually I
thought you were gonna tell me she
stopped reading the comment well no she
still reads them I'm like don't do that
but um she actually said that the car
was the most accurate story that she's
seen so far on me this was a big goal of
mine way before Jason ever emailed me
getting like getting on the cover of my
well I actually wrote it down in my I'm
not kidding I am not kidding I feel so
used
I wrote it down in um
I think with October of 2007 that I
wanted to do it and it's completely
that's totally unrealistic
I don't do fame for famous sake I don't
think it's worth it I don't think it
makes any sense I think that you need a
reason to do it and I wrote you a letter
about that which of course captain
Cocker I said the reason of course get
picked on Cocker you said to Chicago you
published it on your but that's not
sending it to god it's publishing on
your blog eseni it's a god I asked you
for permission that's true what you've
done you know in economic terms what
you've done is created a huge assets in
the reputation economy right I like that
reputation economy did you just come up
with that no have you turned your
celebrity into mine yes actually um the
whole goal for becoming a marquee name
if you will or getting my reputation out
there was for job security given the way
you've got your celebrity and the
controversy and the pros and cons what
product could you what product could you
possibly endorse um I'm really into
personal growth I'm going for the Oprah
model whenever i link to things on my
blog I get I have gotten emails from
owners of companies saying I don't know
who you are but for some reason your
readers all want blank whether it's a
swimsuit that's made out of very Spanx
like material which you don't even know
what that is it's like a slimming device
and if I say I use my Canon camera to
take pictures of myself and to take
videos you better believe that people
are gonna go out and buy that camera and
the dresses I wear and you know the same
way that they do it with celebrities
well celebrities tend to be influential
because they're respected looking
they're respected figures I want to be
like her out there wants to be like you
well that's that's a question nice I
only can sound like a douchebag if I
answer but like go girls I mean young
younger girls especially those who watch
Sex and the City girls
yes I do thank you before for being good
sport well that's the one thing I am and
the cell promoter apparently